the head coach of the nfc east champion
washington football team ron rivera here
on the rich eisen show how are you coach
i'm doing good rich doing well congrats
thank you you are most welcome what if i
told you
in week one that this is the way week 17
would end
how would you have uh handled that
information coach
back then well week one i wouldn't have
agreed uh week five
i would thought definite possibility
that's for sure okay
now in just your own personal journey
here uh this year what does this
division title and right to host
uh tom brady and the buccaneers for the
whole country to sit in and watch on a
a triple header capper of a wild card
saturday what does that mean for you
coach well i i think it
is you know it speaks well to the
resilience of our football
team to the development of our young
players um
and to the triumphant return of alex
smith to football
you know it's um there were a lot of
things that happened this year a lot of
interesting things that happened um
you know we we we we have a lot of young
players that we played this year
at one point i think i counted 28 guys
that were first second and third year
players that have played meaningful
snaps for us
so they're growing and developing as a
football team
um we had alex get this opportunity to
get back on the football field and as a
starter i believe he's five and one for
us
this year so that's pretty exciting um
and you know we granted we did play in
the division that was down
you know that nobody took the bull by
the horn
and that's why in week five i i i
made the move i did in changing
quarterbacks and saying that i wanted to
take our shot at seeing if we can win
the division
and we did uh and we were fortunate
enough to come out on top
you know because again i think our guys
our coaches did a great job in terms of
just
sticking to it working and the thing i
think that was also
beneficial rich was just the fact that
we had something to play for
every every every week you know uh from
from
from start to finish you know we we had
a chance
uh especially as i said started from
week five on
um with the knowledge that nobody was
running away with the division
so what is the conversation with you and
alex smith like and if you don't mind me
setting the story up this way i i
you know the question this way but just
the back story of you
uh a super bowl champion from your
playing days and then uh
somebody trying to get into coaching as
you did and then
a two-time coach of the year uh coaching
a team that makes it to the super bowl
but that organization and you part ways
and you get a new spot and you get a new
spot and you learn that you're battling
cancer
and one of your quarterbacks on the team
is somebody who you don't even know if
you can count on at some point because
for the right reasons a former first
overall selection
in his next new stop his third new team
trying to get an opportunity 17
surgeries is needed to get him back on
the field what is that conversation
after you or both
division champions together like last
night
it was pretty cool um i i i honestly
there really wasn't much of a
conversation i think is more of a
staring looking or not
um is really what it was all about um i
i just happened to
you know i went around i congratulated
everybody and he was doing media
and when we were both pretty much
finished up and heading out
we crossed paths and just kind of caught
eyes and just kind of looked at each
other with smile and nodded at one
another
uh and i patted him on the shoulder as i
walked by him
um it really was a lot more unsaid than
it really was
uh a big conversation to be honest but
that's that that look
said a whole bunch didn't it pretty much
it did to me it did just looking at him
and and
it's interesting because you know on up
until
the uh probably about the the
last two weeks of training camp i really
wasn't sure where alex was
and he had asked to come see me
and so he came in and we started talking
and like i said it's like the last two
weeks of training camping
look at me said um
need to know if i can make it i i need
more of an opportunity
i don't think i'm getting a fair
opportunity to make the team
i really want this i really want to i
looked at myself really he said yes i
really want this
i got to find out i got gotta sign up
for me i just don't want you to
gratulously bring me along or anything
like that i want it
i want more and it's interesting because
with that conversation with him telling
me he wanted more
it made me feel more comfortable to put
him in that situation where he would get
more
that he was ready for it and so i said
you know and i had i had kenny's ampeezy
in here with me and
and and scott turner and i said look he
wants more and if he wants more let's
let's give him every opportunity let's
put him in the middle of these things
let's put him in this situation let's
put him in these circumstances
and we did for the next couple of weeks
of practice
and you know and i won't say they were
live
drills but they're action drills and so
guys were around his feet
guys were falling towards his leg guys
were coming close to him
and he just stood tall and kept throwing
the ball downfield and and it gave me
more and more confidence
and that's why i kept him on the roster
because i just knew as he got more and
more confidence he would get better and
better
and and it just it just kind of
blossomed that way and
and and he it was it was because of his
goating um is the reason why
and and that's the reason why he's he's
been successful because he's
that kind of person he wants it he wants
more
have you turned his leg brace into a
trophy of sorts
his wife has done that his wife
to keep it immobile and somebody showed
me a picture of it and it
and it and it mimics uh a super bowl
trophy
and i think it's very apropos when you
look at it i mean you really do if you
ever get chances no we're showing it on
social media we see it on the screen
here
yeah yeah it looks just it yeah it's a
it's impressive it is incredible it is
incredible and as it turned out coach
ron rivera here on the rich island show
his professionalism
uh is something that you you desperately
needed towards the end here
um a couple of story lines from last
night and just a couple weeks ago i want
to hit with you here
uh is the departure of dwayne haskins
what do you think
happened and what do you think he could
potentially bring
to another team that unfortunately he
did not bring to yours
coach well i i i think you know some
guys at the ohio state had a lot of
success
but i'm not sure if just playing one
full year
um really prepares you for the rigors of
the nfl
and he had a lot to learn and and
he's got i have to have an understanding
of how to prepare how to be a pro
uh the young man has a terrific arm he's
got good athleticism
he's got he's got good movement skills
and he just he just needs to understand
learn and grow and and mature and i
think
you know having you know hit i almost
say rock bottom but but but but you know
at a low point in your career i i think
hopefully this helps him because
he he he's a good young man and he's
just
got to learn some things that will help
him as a football player he
he he has a skill set that can help him
and if he learns and grows and you know
and and
and somebody can mentor him and get him
to to do it the right way
uh i think he can help i really do um
i i i think this also might be a good
opportunity for him
and i just felt at the time that if
parting
ways was the best thing uh for us both
and so hopefully he'll get a good fresh
start um
and he's hopefully learned a lesson or
two that he can carry with him that will
help him
and help them his new team and then
let's get to last night's game
uh coach as i'm sure the conversation um
of of your or your accomplishments got
lost quite a bit
um in the aftermath of the game because
of the insertion of nate sutfeld into
the game when it was
uh winnable for both teams uh what did
you think of
when when sudfeld trotted on the field
last night
i didn't think anything of it um i
really didn't
i i you know it's interesting when when
one team is playing for something and
somebody else isn't
uh the other team can do whatever they
want uh in terms of
um players they play plays they run
i i think you know people get upset
about it
for whatever the reason is but people
don't understand that
a coach is going to do what he thinks is
best for his team's growth and
development
uh going forward and so i don't begrudge
it because
you know you get in these situations
people go well you know look what
happened yeah well look what happened to
us
two weeks ago nobody cared that alex
couldn't play nobody
cared that that that terry mclaurin
wasn't gonna pay
you know nobody said oh let's make it
even you know don't let your starters
play
that that's what happens and so if a
coach decides something you know that's
what he decides i mean i've been in that
situation in the past where
i said hey let's play them all get them
all out there give me opportunities
you know but it's just you know i get it
people want to make something of it
that's fine
if they need something to talk about
that's fine you know i've had people
say you know you should never should
have never gotten the playoffs at 7 8-1
but yet we win a playoff game and
we have a chance to win a second one um
you know
um and and the 2014 season
you know people say oh you shouldn't
have gotten in but at the time we were
hot
we want four in a row to get there so
you know for for
for us to to to tell people what they
should do with their teams and how they
should do it that's that's
that's hey he does what he thinks is
best for his team going forward
ron rivera washington football team head
coach here on the rich eisen show
and you know i don't know how fair it
was coach
to throw a guy who hasn't played in
three years
on the other side of the line of
scrimmage of chase young i mean
he what he what he is doing right now
is quite something can you compare it
because again
you know uh jack del rio dropped the
name of ray lewis
when uh chris collinsworth was calling
the game last night saying that in terms
of just
leadership skills and grown-ass man
skills um this is what
you know he reminds jack you've been
around some 85 bears as well
is there anybody that you can compare
chase young to
ron rivera oh wow i'll tell you what he
he most certainly is a different kind of
football player and
you know maybe maybe as he he grows in
his career
you might have somebody start comparing
him you know to lawrence taylor
um but um i don't want to go there yet
[Laughter]
no i i i could understand why you want
to go there yet but what
what aspects of his game do you think
reminds you
of him then oh his
his love of the game the first one he
loves the game he absolutely loves
everything about the game
right um and he's got some some some
impact playability he's one of those
young guys that came out early and
you know you just wish he had a little
bit more time to continue to grow and
develop
but we got him uh and we're gonna keep
working with them because
i think he's a guy that can be a very
special player someday
we're looking at him that he is right
now because he is a good player
yeah we're looking at him right now um
he went back on the field and
knelt on the 50-yard line um in his
uh championship his i guess his nfc east
championship shirt just kind of soaking
it all in
um that's a different cat right there
man i'll tell you that
that's just he is i'll tell you he's got
that he's got that relentless motor but
the other thing he's got too is
he's got this energy that's infectious
um
to to and it draws people to him you
know what i'm saying and just guys see
the way he does things and next to you
guys pick it up and guys get going and
guys feed off of it
you know it's crazy because he'll go
over
you know during the game and he'll stand
next to me and talk about things and
then he'll go over
and he'll stand next to um he'll stand
next to to
one of the offensive coaches you know
the running backs coach and he'll tell
him
man i like how the way where your guys
running man i've got to keep him going
well coach look i i appreciate the time
here uh on the program and
uh last one for you chase young also
said and we're talking about how special
is
i don't know if you're aware he said
that he he wants to
bring on tom brady he actually said
those words what do you think is his
coach
oh yeah i think he might play against
the best i really do
you know he he's i mean that's him he
loves it he looks
you know i'll tell you this when we're
getting ready to play pittsburgh yeah
and we're going through warm-ups and and
he sees ben roethlisberger
and he comes up and he goes damn that's
ben roethlisberger man i tell you this
exciting coach is exciting
he said i want to get to know ben and i
said relax you'll get your chance
well so then he goes warms up and comes
back now ben is closer to
midfield and moral standover midfield he
sees he just runs over there shakes
ben's hand
i mean he is so excited he's a football
guy you know that expression
i i i want guys that love playing
professional football right not being
professional football players
that's chase he loves playing the game
he loves everything about the game
he gets excited he gets excited about
this is tom brady
i'm gonna be on the same field as tom
brady he's gonna be this on the same
field
as gronkowski i mean that's the way he
looks at it i mean
it's it's it is it is it is such a
such a kid-like attitude about the game
it's
fun for him okay then uh that's the way
you're you you know cause sometimes
people say bring them on and
they they they rue the the word saying
that but you're saying it comes from
a different place is what you're saying
wrong oh without a doubt without a doubt
just because
because i got to see how he was when he
saw ben roethlisberger right
that was cool you know what i'm saying i
mean it's it's it's honestly
it's like how i felt when i sat there
and saw joe montana
i mean you said that's freaking joe
montana
are you kidding me i love it that's
terrific
all right coach uh coach ron rivera here
on the rich eisen show
congrats on uh on making the playoffs
winning the division
and uh uh continuing this remarkable
and uh frequently painful and dramatic
but
ultimately rewarding journey for you
this year coach i appreciate the time
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here